debate club how about that yes wrap it
up the first one is from Trey from
Pittsburgh Trey way Pittsburgh do the
Monongahela boy got them Stewie eyes
confluence oh [ __ ] Lee part we're in
Boston Massachusetts my name is Justus
my brother Steven we're just wondering
we don't have a little debate ourselves
Tupac or biggie think my intentions of
the rod rod rod rod rod you know any
biggie songs do before we lose sooner
money man I'd lose Oh fat little Kim
going to prison that's all you got it
was all a dream
come on dude it was all a dream
you to read to you read Word Up Magazine
some pepper on my on my peen okay we
don't know the song he's doing but you
know what they're both dead
they're both dead so listen do park in a
[ __ ] heartbeat brah
really - part 3 part 4 part 5 part
island island island island today let's
go to Derrick first let's feel like you
can't worst of all - cated then you on
racket let's go to the yeah let's get
some people's go crazy the culture
corner with Derek and catapulter going
with Derek and cat I'm gonna say biggie
all day cuz smoothness you know me -
buck always sound like he's gonna fight
you you know I'm interesting like that
he always kind of aggressive you also
know Tupac went to Juilliard so it's
going slow your gangster down yeah oh
yeah yeah I like Tupac biggie is better
lyrically but I grew up with you box
though didn't we all my own inner kid
the one who bought the theater kid he's
a straight theatre kid yeah that had a
tattoo of thug life on his tummy so not
very thuggy yeah what was the biggest
thug you ever played he was in Othello
wasn't he yeah he was dude
he was he's also in Peter Pan in stir
you know I'm saying yeah uh if I have to
pick I don't know
you know what ruins it for biggie for me
was [ __ ] P Diddy just yeah nuts for a
little bit dude
maybe not Ryder dude that's all he did
all open the videos when there's all
this talent yeah I'm the P Diddy of
comedy like I'm just like you're biggie
I'm solid yeah I've no business being
here but I'm like in the jumpsuit all up
in your video you are that's good all
dude yeah but P Diddy you're right man
who know I don't know how I mean P Diddy
seem like the dark arts a little bit
he's almost like that like the person
like you know you kind of wonder what
he's up to how I even got manage his way
through it all and he's the only dance
moves he is the whitest [ __ ] dance
moves ever it always look like he kind
of dropped something and then remember
him in mace huh marry him in mace how
did those two navigate their lives like
remember the rap video where they're
both didn't [ __ ] shimmery [ __ ]
velcro sooo yeah and it's you know that
video which one is it it was so epic but
you're watching like how did these two
get a [ __ ] music video like bumping
in each other both have [ __ ] CTE he's
doing the [ __ ] Harlem shake ya know
yeah dude so but now but then he must be
the best businessman he's just a
champion he's a champion businessman or
the people he works with are and also
men I hear he party you know he's I
don't know man did he's got to be there
must be something really amazing about
him I was at a gym one time in Hollywood
and they kicked everybody out cuz he
came in with his crew no way and I would
you do you hid under the water no I
refuse to leave and they let me stay
yeah I bawled me for the rest of the
time dude that's coming under the house
that's crazy let them tell what is it
eighteen seventy do they seem like the
most racial thing am I gonna call me
white boy
oh my dumb tells you got them towels
mm-hmm and then I drove them around for
the rest of the day dude when I used to
go to Louisiana State they had um you
know this was silk to shock or a
c-murder uh to come and play hoops and
masturbate mr. cow oh do this to cow
dude I [ __ ] saw a mystical doing coke
at a car wash of course you did the Lord
dude [ __ ] bouncing back the hot boys
oh dude here's the thing Master P would
show up right this is when he was trying
to get on a Charlotte Hornets right
never happened but yeah sure no bro so
he would show up Silkk the Shocker was
there see murder was there they were all
playing hoops they would play at the rec
center and they had these dudes that
were dressed up like in all these gold
chains and everything who would stand on
the side with their arms straight out
and hold their like towel and their
extra shoes and clothes like in their
homes like this man do you remember
Silkk the Shocker at that that big ass
hit
what was his hit Silkk the Shocker you
got the biggest hit man I remember I
wasn't fully murder killed a couple guys
and then they let him out of jail and
he's like I wanna know what I'll do kill
someone in the back oh thanks let me out
no you go bro free mystical prison he
went back he got out and made a hit song
and then right back Silkk the Shocker
had that [ __ ] oh it ain't my fault
this goes big-ass hit though mystical
had a bunch of hits dude Oh
mystical the hot boys huh
y'all is ain't ready yet I don't know it
where is it man Oh yet the rape charge
enough you know working with watch them
shake here I go yeah oh that's right
that's about it
yep there's two of them that's cool yeah
man that's it though all right gang bro
he's in prison now for rape so you know
you still made the head stuff yeah no
ray buddy you don't do that kind of
stuff you got to tighten up mr. cool not
so hot anymore are you boys yeah
53% of people said Tupac gang now who
died earlier who died first Tupac died
and then Biggie died so that's
interesting inside in a 2-bike died in
Vegas biggie died here Wow
everyone thinks the CI a [ __ ] a
what's the consensus in the in the
cultural community guys you guys are
Vietnamese and you know I think it
depends on what city you in and Derek if
you're if you're anywhere the middle of
the country this way people can say
Tupac Miller country that way I think
huh so you think he gets regional I
think it's rude here's the other thing
though is P Diddy still I won't shut the
[ __ ] up about biggie
so it's always in our face ain't no one
really repping Tupac
yeah [ __ ] he ran over three guys
tomorrow someone give him a Slurpee so
he killed all three I thought no one
would notice into on 18 we all watch
this dude thank God we still got yellow
wolf boy you feel me broccoli me
get your life together touch me bro I'm
not touching